the video that I want to do today is a
direct follow-up of the one I did a few
weeks ago with Sean so what misguidedly
entitled the most difficult program to
compute question mark it was of course
all about the Ackermann function today I
want to show to you the busy beaver
problem of the busy beaver game and it
is far worse than Ackerman it was
invented by a gentleman called Tibor
Rado in 1962 what he in his later years
took on was to teach beginners about
Turing machines now many of you on the
Sean and Brady wish list of topics to be
covered that I'm willing about Turing
machines I want to know about
undecidability so this is a lovely way
to pull it all in because this thing
this program that behaves even worse
than Ackerman depends and is utterly
related to the idea of a chewing machine
for those of you want just a bit more
detail about what's going on at the
Turing machine level and exactly how to
bore Rado developed a particular form of
Turing machine suitable for this game
then I'm going to refer you to this
short introductory movie so let's look
at the particular formulation of a
Turing machine the Tibble Rado
formulated as a game which you can play
with your computer program and in fact
those web pages devoted to this you can
join in on the busy beaver community and
see if you can find a beaver that's even
busier than the ones currently known but
be warned as you want to go up and up
and up in size of this problem it goes
up worse than super exponentially this
is the single state Turing machine for
the busy beaver problem what the heck is
this busy beaver problem busy beaver
asks what is the maximum number of ones
that get printed on your tape for your
given Turing machine
when it holds now I've got to have that
to the end because as you'll discover
there are some there are lots of rogue
Turing machines which will go berserk
either printing endless ones or even
overwriting them with endless zeros and
going either to the right or to the left
so these well behaved ones we want them
to halt and stop and just leave
big big tape with lost ones and zeros on
it and it's called busy beaver because
this program is just going bananas
walking up and down the tape writing
ones and zeros seemingly arbitrarily but
in accordance with the program
instructions on the cards and you're
just saying how many ones do I end up
with what's the best or worst I can do
well I think this will become a bit more
alive to you now if we take a real
actual example of a single card during
machine for busy beaver so we stick our
read/write head in the middle of this
tape to start off with there it is and
this is card one it is the only card
available to us because this is a one
card Turing machine rule is your start
card is always called one the first
thing you say is read a symbol so you
read a zero okay what does the
instruction card tell me to do it says
overwrite it with a 1 as the overwritten
1 0 remember means move to the left and
make 0 so you move the head to here 1
that means go back to instruction card 1
I'm already in instruction 1 so what I
do is go back in there like that but now
again you say read what's under the head
while the heads move to here but you're
under another 0 now so you say ok
overwrite that 0 with a 1 shift to the
left because that's what the 0 means
I'll prime you move the head here go
back to state 1 we're already in state 1
go back and do it again you can see
straight away what's going to happen
here I'm going to whiz off to the left
writing ones and it will never never
stop so here's the first example then
of what I referred to in the previous
video I told you there were things
called recursively enumerable programs
that sometimes stops and sometimes just
whizzed into loops and went on forever
well it's a nice simple example of it
given that right at the start you
probably don't know whether your given
program is going to whiz it left or
right or whether it's just going to mess
about in the middle start it in the
middle give it enough space to go left
enough supposed to go right but the
rules say in principle if it needs
infinite tape give it enough now a lot
of the art of this kind of programming
is to say Arbit is it looping it's
pointless giving it infinite tape if
it's just going to loop and loop and
loop and not do any different thing
forever and yeah very very clearly this
one's looping so we've done a one card
turing machine busy beaver attempt here
and just seen how easy it is to get into
a loop and spin off doing zillions of
ones that will their end and you might
say oh that's the idea then is it a sort
of infinite busy beaver it just spews
out ones forever
and unfortunately rules the games they
know that doesn't count it's got to halt
there's got to be a finite number of
ones that you can count ones that just
go on forever don't count so you need to
get into a whole state somehow or
another and have a finite number ones to
count up so let's do one that is still a
single card candidate for a busy beaver
Turing machine but one that doesn't loop
indefinitely this time I'm going to make
it be zero if I read a zero then I my
actions are 1 1 0 actually some of you
will have spotted already that in a 1
card set up like this given that you
move the head off to the left on the
right all you ever encounter is zeros
you are not going to get into a stage of
ever reading a 1 because she wrote you
only got one instruction and you either
keep reow baying it as we saw last time
when you loop back into itself or it's a
one-off thing and it does one thing and
stops and in this particular case well
I'll put 1 1 0 here
for the one case we won't need that
because look what happens if I've read a
zero which I have there what do I then
do the answer is I overwrite it with a
one the next one to the right of that in
the instruction layout says shift right
remember a zero at that position is
shift left this one is shift right so I
shift the read/write head to the right
but then C 0 is the halt State Wow bound
to win an award it reads a zero it's
over writes it with a 1 it shifts one
place to the right and then stops
wonderful extremes isn't it it either
whizzed ease off and never stops writing
ones or else it does precisely 1:1 and
then stops and says done it let's just
do a bit of mental arithmetic here it's
not too difficult in this case you've
got 0 or a 1 as the things you might be
reading but here you've got a triple a
binary digits it's either north or one
that you read you see the north or
walnut you shift left or right and it's
either the whole state or back into one
which is where you go right so Shawn you
start off at 10 2 to the power 3 is 8
you've got that in the zero case and in
general you've also got to say well I've
got 8 possibilities for the one case so
8 times 8 is 64 there are 64 one card
turing machines but there's only about 4
possible behaviors you either off to the
left printing and overwriting the cells
with either one's always zeros or you
can write a 1 shift to the left and stop
one shift to the right and stop or
overwrite a zero with a zero shift to
the left and stop or shift to the right
and stop not exactly thrilling but since
the aim of the busy beaver game is how
many ones
can you write regardless of which of the
64 cars you choose and you must try them
all out the answer is you never get
better than one you write one one rado
in his paper cause the score Sigma Greek
Sigma the score for a one card busy
beaver the best you can do is what
remember this cheering machines are just
made up
of sets of cards in order that's all so
for the order - you're going to have a
c1 and c2 if you're having a c2
possibility a two card thing then that
final column could be nought to hold it
one to go back into yourself or two to
go to the other card
so you've got three possibilities in
that final column now so it's not like 2
times 2 times 2 it's 2 times 2 times 3
anyway you work it all out for the 2
card case would you believe there are
20,000 736 Turing machines 20,000 736
this number which is just how many
Turing machines have you got to look at
to see which behaves the best in
printing out lots of ones this only goes
up exponentially this number this isn't
bad but each one of those machines can
behave worse than super exponentially so
rao's number 4 how many Turing machines
you can seat in his paper I'll leave you
to work out for yourself why this is
true the number of Turing machines let's
call it n of n is 4 times n plus 1 all
raised to the power of 2 n let's see if
that works if I put in 1 here for n
right 1 plus 1 is 2 2 4 8 8 to the power
of 2 times 1 2 times 1 is 2 8 squared 64
right what about if I put in n is 2 2
plus 1 is 3 3 times 4 is 12 12 to the
power of 4 12 to power of 4 is twenty
thousand 736
so your first job is to enumerate all
those Turing machines just get all those
possible to card combinations that make
20,000 736 different possibilities and
you can start to weed out the rubbish
straight away you can clearly say first
of all if you're chosen machine doesn't
have a halt stay somewhere in it then
it's never ever going to stop and it
can't be a content
so you can rule out all the ones that
don't have a zero somewhere in a
right-hand column you can soon get rid
of those out cut it down a little bit
but then you have to start running the
Turing machines to see like I've done
here do they hold if they hold how many
ones have they written by the time
they've halted it tends to be the case
that all the ones that get written
pretty well bunched together but the
rules of the game saying that's not
absolutely essential just start at the
far left with the earliest one read
across to the right and count at the
number ones you've got and that's your
score but it must hold it mustn't be in
part of her I'm going on forever sort of
loop there are some candidates for best
busy beaver of the two card turing
machine what's the maximum number of
ones that they can print out for not
very good anything what's all the fuss
about when you get on to three card
turing machines how many of these are
there on your shortlist 16,777,216
three-card Turing machines what's the
best score you can get off a three card
machine still only six doesn't look very
ominous or dreadful at this stage four
card ones how many of those are there
now I've gone up to about four card ones
in the program I'll give you the answer
is twenty five point six trillion
possible Turing machines all of which
have to be run and their behavior
investigated all they have to be
eliminated these are for card machines
what's the best score you can get off
those thirteen and this goes worse than
Ackerman yeah this is the false dawn it
just goes berserk now when you come on
to five-card busy beavers which is where
this huge research still going on the
best score so far four five card try
machine I have not worked out how many
of those are are it's going to be huge
all of which have to be investigated the
best score for a five card so far is
four thousand and
ninety-eight it's coming up to 25 years
ago that that number was discovered 4098
is the best yet so I hear you say what
are they messing about at about 25 years
and all right there's a few trillion
quadrillion Turing machines to be
investigated but all the obvious rubbish
would have been weeded out by now I may
say that the German researchers who
discovered this number did have access
to a supercomputer it does help
what's gone wrong why isn't there a
better result and if you look on the
Wikipedia page for this you'll find the
answer the house there is that there are
40 candidates still running which might
produce an even better answer than 4098
and you say but surely the darn things
are either discernibly looping or else
they've stopped no it's really horrible
this is a nasty part of it you can get
Turing machines where you can't tell
whether they're looping or not they
consume a lot of tape and then they come
back and they overwrite bits of the tape
and you know and you think have I seen
that pattern before in the case that I
did for the once nature machine we're
just go 1 1 1 1 1 1 over it takes no
genius to say it's looping and it's
doing nothing reproducing ones but you
can imagine that as the numbers go up
you could get very very long cyclic
periodicity with the periodicity of 20
million or something like this Tibor
Rado and his student were the people who
worked out that for a four-car machine
13 was the best result you could get but
in getting that result they still had to
look at a handful of rogue machines they
weren't sure whether they stopped or not
some of them they could prove
programmatically were definitely looping
others they could use human inference to
argue yes that is looping I can show you
why
so yeah 13 is definitely correct but for
the five case who knows
join the busy beaver club get your own
supercomputer do the work
and somebody out there has gone on to
order six and it is reckoned that the
minimum possible score for an order six
busy beaver will be of the order 10 ^
10,500
now that's getting very close in size to
a command for two you know it to ^ sixty
something thousand nobody knows what the
right score is so can you see that's
already by order five or six you're
getting into a command size numbers and
one of the things shown on the wikipedia
page which will delight you is that for
all sufficient n and n is not very big
busy beaver numbers will always outrank
ackerman numbers and the reason for that
is that again in the literature which
you can look up for yourself the reason
is that the busy beaver can be shown to
grow faster than any computable function
it doesn't matter what you put in there
but if it's a computable function that
has an answer busy beaver can be shown
to grow faster than that in the long run
it may not do fishes for small then but
eventually it'll overtake it and go
completely mad so yes the answer to the
horrible question is are you telling me
this thing gives you even bigger numbers
and acumen does yes it does effortlessly
bigger
some people say I don't believe all the
stuff about recursively enumerable
sometimes it can you know sometimes this
machine can stop and give you an answer
and sometimes it just whizzes around
forever well here you've got it in front
of you and it really it is not
terrifically useful except it's here as
a teaching example of saying it may seem
pointless but this is the worst can
happen with a computer program you set
on the face of it what seems to be a
perfectly straightforward thing run this
cheering machine hope it halts and then
tell me how many ones it prints out but
behind that is a huge amount of
illustration of theory you think I'll
that's going to be no worse than super
exponential even when it explodes and
takes off this one Rockets up far faster
than a common and very often you will
say if problems are badly behaved they
are either super exponential or they may
be even worse they may actually be
undecidable and this is what you are
saying in this thingy